[Music]
throughout history
different cultures reference a great
tournament
mortal kombat
my name is jax sonia liu kang kong loves
[Applause]
[Music]
in theaters and on hbo max april 16
radar
[Music]
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in brazil
to capture a wanted fugitive
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
the target has superhuman abilities
[Applause]
[Music]
it had the same marking you do cole
it's a birthmark what do you mean he was
born with it
it's not a birthmark cole means you've
been chosen
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
of champions that dragon marking
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
[Applause]
as mortal kombat
these are your champions i'm sonia
that's kano
the fate of earth is in our
no heads how many of my people you put
in the ground
we will not fail kill them
[Music]
i am zero
[Applause]
get over here
you [ __ ] beauty
[Music]
foreign